i haven't seen anything like that
in my long long activist life i'm
i'm an activist since 2007 so i'm around
for 13 years
and i haven't seen um um protests
spreading so far
um and the importance of this protest
is uh that it's not just moscow's
embarrassment or
the biggest cities um the protest is
happening even
in smaller cities of russia and that's
really crucial
but also another thing that i haven't
seen um throughout
this 13 years is the reaction because we
are staying
um unbelievable repressive
uh wave against political activists
thousands
are arrested people are facing jail time
including masha lahina who is a member
of pusira she's the co-founder of
israeli who spent
two years in jail with me and now she's
placing another two years in jones
she is under house arrest currently and
now were you out on the
streets yourself
um i wasn't i'm coordinating it from um
i'm part of the media team so i'm in
charge of coordinating
protesters from the outside but we all
saw
those pictures as you touch on there of
the
the response from the authorities the
thousands upon thousands of
riot police out on the streets of major
russian cities
what does that tell us about president
putin and his supporters just how
worried are they
well yeah um it's it's a common stasis
actually um why uh cushion would be so
scared and
um um send all these police to the
streets uh to confront peaceful
protesters if he
is so sure about his approval rating um
so um it's been like um a common mistake
that i've heard
from people a lot many people thought
that putin
has actually have big approval rating
but the thing is
uh you can't really talk about the pro
ratings in australian
countries right um you have to see um
you have to see the broader picture and
the broader picture is
that uh navalnese um is the
leader of russian opposition currently
jailed
his um latest video
gained 100 million views on youtube
over just a week which covers um
more than half of russia almost every
adult
russian citizen has watched that uh
documentary
about putin's palace on the black sea
about his corruption and about his
crimes
so um the um if you if you see the
picture in
whole complexity you will see that putin
doesn't have
um that much support in 2021
and are you worried about alexey navalny
of course he faces
court tomorrow for violating his
parole for for missing uh a hearing with
his
parole officer because he was recovering
from being poisoned in a hospital in
in germany we're hearing he could face
something like three three and a half
years in jail
um that's impossible the cruelty and uh
hypocrisy just
um it doesn't make sense the cruelty and
hypocrisy of the russian government
because
first they poison him and then they say
that he is missing their parole hearing
what um three and a half years is a
really
comfortable um amount of time for the
kremlin because they will be able to
transfer
their power um nicely and smoothly
from putin to putin as they're planning
to do in the next few years
and definitely they don't do not want to
have alexey navalny
the biggest pudding critic around for
this transition
people in the united kingdom people in
so many countries that
uh love freedom watching with with
horror
what's been taking place on the streets
of those russian cities as we've
discussed is there anything more
that you think i mean we've heard
condemnations from the
new american presidents from the foreign
secretary here
in the united kingdom is there anything
more practical though
that could be done to put pressure on
president putin from your point of view
um yeah i think it should be personal
sanctions you should
follow the money because um one thing
you need to understand about
um russian elites is that they call
themselves patriots but
they're not really um thinking um
they're not really living in russia
so their families their kids and um most
of their time they are actually spending
outside of russia
so um if europe um
united states and all those countries
where our bureaucrats
are elites actually like to leave if
they would investigate
where this money come from they will see
that this money are stolen from russian
people and this money are illegal
so um i would say personal sanctions
never sanctions against russian citizens
because russian citizens need to feel
like they can actually at some point be
part of the free world and uh they
don't i don't want anyone to feel
threatened by
the west because that's what our
government does they say oh the
government the western countries are
going to put sanctions against you
personally
but um what we need to do what you need
to do is to
make sanctions against pushing them his
groundings well nadia turlock
it's been very good talking to you very
brave young woman thank you very much
indeed
thank you so much